weren you supposed to take the shahada
man you want me to take it right
now yeah why not all right help
me it's God it's it's
God it's
God weren you supposed to take the
shahada man you want me to take it right
now yeah why not all right help me I'm
not forcing you into you're not forcing
me go ahead lead me into the sh let's go
n you're not
serious what what is the sh the sh is
just a statement of faith
right no what is
it you don't know no man I don't know
everything help me I'm see I'm highly
blessed at this moment that you're
trying to you're trying to get informed
about Islam you
know yeah yeah Allah will make good
things for you thank don't worry thank
you yeah yeah yeah but first you got to
struggle like this you got to talk bad
about Muslims talk bad about Islam and
stuff like that wor Allah Allah honors
the struggle he honors the everything
brings you closer to Allah you know you
think so everything yeah yeah let me
tell you something man you know what
would bring me close to Allah and I'm
serious being serious what is if I see
that Allah in through Muhammad is
connected and agrees with the previous
prophets that's what would bring me
close to Allah you will see when you
become not blind yeah you will see well
I'm only blind because of Allah
right no yeah he says that he guides who
he wants and he misguides who he wants
so the only reason why I'm blinded right
now is because Allah is BL the only
reason you're blind is because you
follow a human God my friend but that's
because Allah did this Allah made me
believe
this L you can't blame Allah does any
does anything happen without Allah's
will with what does anything happen
outside of Allah's
will do we have free will no I said does
anything happen outside of Allah's
will everything is Allah's will yeah
right so he I'm I'm a disbeliever right
now because Allah will for me to be a
disbeliever
right um Allah has a correct path for
disbelievers you know he can't give you
blessings if you're a disbeliever would
you give I'm only a disbeliever because
Allah willed that I'm a disbeliever
right no because you chose to be a
disbeliever so I'm able so I'm able to
go outside of Allah's
will no Allah's will is the correct path
for you and the wrong path for you which
other you take it's Allah's will I'm a
little confused here Allah says that
Allah says that he guides and death
you're you're familiar with the verse
where Allah says that he guides whom he
Wills right and he misguides whom he
Wills oh yeah yeah so the ones who are
misguided are misguided by
Allah no the ones that are misguided are
misguided by Allah by their
own yeah okay I'm a I'm a disbeliever
cuz i' I've been misguided by Allah to
disbelieve bro you can't blame
why would you blame me for something
that Allah wrote in my faith 40 years
before I was born
bro uh okay I can't say I'm Allah you
know I can't say I'm a
God you say you're a God but look at
this way you know if you want to test
people in order for the people to get
into Paradise you know how can how can
you send them to Paradise without
testing you know how or you going to say
okay people 1+ 1 equals two you're going
to Paradise what's the answer two okay
go to paradise you can't do that you
know but that's not that's not really
that's not really dealing with the Crux
of the issue though you know it's it's
we're we're talking about Allah himself
being the one who has misguided me into
this disbelief and you know he wrote he
wrote this for me Allah has put you here
on a test with 500 more religions you
know so on this test he's misguiding me
to get the wrong answers with
testest yourself you know but if you
choose the left or the right path there
is another path that leads to that path
but how can I choose how can I choose
against what Allah has already wrote for
me you have free will no I know yeah
he's okay he wrote for you for example
if dog logic goes left he will be
blessed if dog logic goes right why are
you calling me a dog I can't say God you
know God love doesn't make sense but why
call me a dog though okay sorry puppy
logic sorry what is that puppy
puppy why why are you calling me a dog
though why not did I disrespect you
that's not disrespect if you called me a
dog I wouldn't get disrespected what if
I called Muhammad a dog would you C that
is
disrespectful yeah I would get
disrespected so why why so why do you
think that's disrespectful to call
Muhammad a
dog that's another topic look at your
topic it's another topic so you see so
you're I just I just look you know why
you're wait wait a second bullet bullet
hold on a second C we're talking bro
we're talking even even though even
though you know you disrespect me and
stuff like that I can still talk to you
you know what I'm saying there's no
problem with me I'm not I'm not offended
I just you know I like for you can hide
I like for the 500 people here and the
400 people on YouTube to see how Muslims
Act when you know you you guys you guys
talk now you said you know calling
someone a dog is not disrespectful but
uh even you you said I could call you a
dog you wouldn't take it as disrespect
so but if I were to call Muhammad a dog
thanks hey thanks gospel truth
appreciate you man that means a lot
coming from you bro uh he say he says he
says he said hold one second you said if
I if I call Muhammad a dog though you
would take that as disrespect I want to
know why why is it disrespectful if I
called Muhammad a dog
why because the devil is playing games
on you you know that's why but what's
disrespectful about calling Muhammad was
just a man why why why is it
disrespectful if I call Muhammad a dog
or a donkey or a
pig why is it disrespectful because it's
disrespectful you making your soul dirty
okay I got you so look I I'll tell I'll
tell you this I will refrain from
calling Muhammad a dog or pig or you
know whatever he really is
uh as long as you keep it respectful is
that
fair yeah yeah yeah problem all right
got it so if you want to call me by my
username you can call me if you're
uncomfortable saying God logic it's fine
just call me logic okay can do you have
a nickname do you have call meog I don't
no I don't want to call you
log that's what you that's I call you
can I call you Trinity now you call me
logic I want to call you three Gods can
I call you NOP you got to call me logic
okay I don't want to call you that all
right so then just uh just don't say my
name then just when you refer to me
don't don't don't say a name nope I I'll
just say sir sir that's fine I
appreciate that or or sire yeah that's
that's sire sire sounds good I I I I
would rather you call call Jesus sire
though I want you to call him okay
before I drop before I drop
bro why would you drop I want you to
stay we got to talk because I don't want
to cook you man you look too cooked you
don't want to cook me yeah you're
getting you're not you're not hungry
you're getting offended by the word dog
you know that the same way that you get
offended by the word dog from Muhammad
I'm not offender you know you are if I
said that Muhammad's a dog you said that
that's
offensive okay have a good night I'll be
watching you okay thank you you too
man for for the guy who um who just
and he's listening if you're
uncomfortable calling me God logic or
logic anything like that call me shake
call me shake because I I do teach Islam
I I help you guys learn the Quran I
teach your your religion and then I
expose your religion for how false it is
and how disgusting it is
so yeah call me shake that's that's
another nickname for if it's not logic
call me shake shake logic you know oh my
God
[Music]
logic